I received a video on Twitter from
Jeremy McClellan who's a comedian who
lives in South Carolina about a video
that he filmed inside of a Trader Joe's
a friend of comedian Jeremy mcclellans
who wishes to remain anonymous says that
she and her friend were in line at
Trader Joe's when a woman got in line
behind them the woman behind them seemed
to be in a hurry it's this woman that's
pictured here over my shoulder and so
they allowed her to go in front of her
okay here's a Facebook post sort of
explaining what took place where Jeremy
McClellan said A friend of mine who
wishes to remain anonymous just sent
this to me I've confirmed that it's real
this happened today at the Trader Joe's
in Reston Virginia this woman was in a
hurry so my friend who's a Muslim woman
offered to let her go in front of her in
line that's when she started talking bad
about a different Muslim woman in the
store who was wearing a kneecub and
asked my friend why she didn't cover as
well my friend replied it's a choice and
the woman didn't believe her and started
talking about FGM and telling her I wish
they don't let you in the country that's
where my friend started filming let's
pick it up there and as you can imagine
the video is absolutely outrageous take
a look at this
foreign
I wish they didn't let you in the
country
excuse me huh I was born here I don't
know if you oh you were
Obama's not in office anymore
we don't have a Muslim in there anymore
yeah I wish he was gone he's gone yeah
he may be in jail too in the future
you look a little crazy maybe you need
to get some help oh I'm fine no you're
not because you don't just strike up a
conversation with people in line talking
about stuff like that if you're normal
I'm very normal yeah it looks like it I
can tell
[Music]
what set you off Obama
[Music]
so I I want to address this in a couple
ways number one the there was a mention
made in there of you look crazy
it's easy to just say oh this is a
mentally ill woman most mentally ill
people aren't racist islamophobic
ideologues who aggressively confront
random people in grocery stores right
Obama may be in jail who could possibly
believe this stuff so I think it's
important I know we colloquially say
this woman is insane but most people who
struggle with mental illness don't have
the thoughts nor audacity to say this
stuff that this woman has yeah and a lot
of the times when you're in a
confrontation you say things that you
later regret even though you may have
been in the right in that argument sure
and Defenders of this woman or something
I mean I don't know who would possibly
defend this woman started saying oh this
entire video was staged in some way yeah
there was a staged racist woman out at a
Trader Joe's and it was sent through a
chain of custody of the video I mean
it's just absurd the entire thing is
going viral Jeremy McClellan told us
that we could use the video for a story
to have the audacity to do this I mean
many here's the reality okay
many people think what this woman said
but most people have the decency not to
publicly say these things particularly
to people that they don't know this
woman clearly had no filter and that's a
particular level of aggression towards
people who are not like you she had an
entire grocery cart there and all that
was in there was a handful of avocados
who does that is that true are you able
to I didn't even notice that are you
able to still the the video at that
point so I can look at that that I want
to examine the contents of This Woman's
cart to figure out what it is that's
going on uh I did that did not even
occur to me oh yeah look at that look at
that there's it's just a cart it looks
like there's it's just a bag of avocados
in a cart
who gets a cart for just four avocados I
think that's the real question and she
was in a hurry too yeah who were you in
a hurry to do make guacamole there's a
lot more to this story I think than than
what has been revealed so far but
needless to say yeah I mean this is
um this is sort of like the worst sort
of person that you could possibly bump
into and I've met
probably a couple people like this woman
in terms of level of aggression when it
comes to others and uh it's it's just
unpleasant to be around yeah and of
course she has freedom of speech to say
whatever she wants but also the other
woman in the grocery store has freedom
of religion to uh practice their own
religion and um you know that doesn't
mean that these things can't uh affect
you negatively and you can't be publicly
embarrassed for being out in public and
saying these things no doubt about it
and that is exactly what is happening
here